hi reject nation I'm Greg Alba we'll
start with you what's your name my name
is Samuel Blanc you can follow them both
on Instagram we have a banner right here
and also go check out the man-eaters
trailer guys it's a film that they
started together it looks pretty bitchin
high five yes you guys you know act
together your co-stars in a film
transition we're gonna watch a video
today from looper called co-stars who
couldn't stand each other off-camera the
biopic about Christina and Kelly Russo
whoo I'm excited I made this right
before you guys showed up I cannot wait
for you guys before we hop into this I
wanted to say thank you to everyone
who's been following us on our patreon
page over there we do weekly Q&A is TV
show reactions for many of shows that
include its attack on Titan my hero
academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood Gotham Thor there's photos
going over all of this so you guys don't
have to like make facial expressions
well I'm saying this be getting the way
you guys are in real life does music
video coverage yay let's watch this it's
a list video so let's get into this and
then we'll talk about it
some celebrities have earned a serious
reputation for difficulty among their
co-stars I heard so much so that other
actors don't ever want to work with them
again from simple personality conflicts
to deranged name-calling and everything
in between
let's take a look at some of the most
infamous co-star beefs and how they got
started Jim Carrey and Tommy Lee Jones
Jim Carrey starred as the Riddler in
Batman Forever he was at the height of
his comedic career but his co-star Tommy
Lee Jones who played Harvey Dent was
definitely not a fan of Harry slapstick
style director Joel Schumacher confirmed
that Jones had something of an attitude
onset telling Entertainment Weekly Jim
Carrey was a gentleman
and Tommy Lee was threatened by him I'm
tired of defending over poor privileged
actors but a direct night before filming
a scene together Kerry and Jones ran
into each other at a restaurant when
Kerry approach Jones's table to say
hello he didn't get quite the greeting
he expected Kerry told Howard Stern that
he got up kind of shaking and hugged me
and said I hate you I really don't like
you I was like wow what's going on man
and he said I cannot sanction your
buffoonery very few people are both the
summer and the winter
you pull it off nicely Wesley Snipes and
romaine Reynolds I heard about that on
Walt's account of his time on the set of
2004 a Trinity is arguably far more
interesting than watching the movie
according to Oslo director David s Goyer
should be blamed for the way the movie
turned out is he spend half of his time
dealing with the erratic behavior of
winging Man Wesley Snipes and he'd walk
by his trailer and this wall of pot
stench he also claims Snipes tried to
strangle the director at one point which
led to go here hiring a bunch of bikers
as bodyguards
according to Oswald that freak Wesley
out so much that for the rest of the
production he would only communicate
with the director through post-it notes
and he would sign each post-it note from
bloom it wasn't just Gore that Snipes
clashed with however the mercurial
action star also failed to get along
with co-star Ryan Reynolds apparently
refusing to even call it by his name
Reynolds laughed when asked if he would
ever consider reuniting with Snipes for
a fourth blade movie answering with an
emphatic no wow
Will Smith and Janet Hubert if you're a
dedicated Fresh Prince of bel-air fan
you're probably aware that the actress
who played on Vivian was replaced
halfway through the series but you might
not know why Janet Hubert portrayed on
film on the show until 1993 when she was
replaced with Daphne Reeve who continued
in the role until Fresh Prince ended its
run in 1996 according to accounts from
show insiders and even humored herself
Smith and his other co-stars were
needlessly cruel to her on the set for
his part Smith knocked down Hubert's
allegations in a 1993 interview with an
Atlanta radio station claiming she had a
bad attitude while filming and adding
the matter what to her on just the
Antichrist in 2011 humored fired back
telling TMZ that she'd never worked with
Smith again Tom Sizemore and Val Kilmer
Sizemore star was on
Rison Holyrood thanks in particular to
his roles in great dramatic films like
1995's heat which he featured in
alongside Val Kilmer but when Kilmer and
Sizemore reunited five years later on
the set of Red Planet things weren't so
rosy reportedly Kilner was upset when he
learned that the production had paid the
shift size for its exercise equipment to
Australia where filming was taking place
reporting the sighs noise my it's a
miracle I made it out of there a
shouting match erupting which ended with
Tom throwing a 50 pound weight at Kilmer
producer asked Sizemore to avoid hitting
Kilmer in the face when they got into
their next fight dutifully slugging
Kilmer in the chest and telling him I'm
never going to another planet with you
again finally very good as of 2014
Robert Downey jr. and Terrence Howard
has known and shy about discussing his
falling out with Iron Man co-star Robert
Downey jr. in 2013 Howard appeared on
Bravo's watch what happens live
discussing the three-picture deal which
the studio had originally offered him
they came to me with the second and said
look we will pay you
1/8 of what we contractually have for
you he went on to put the blame firmly
on Downey's shoulders and I called my
friend that I helped get the first job
and he didn't call me back for three
months it would take another three years
for the pair to finally patch up their
differences when they reunited at the
2016 wedding of director Brian Grazer
Wow I did not know that I did not know
the last one I've always heard Terrence
Howard is a hard guy to work with I've
heard that from many accounts I've heard
about that what he's talking about
there's gay 180 that would actually make
sense I think about because I remember
Robert Downey got paid like 500k to do
the first Iron Man movie which is so
tiny compared to what he gets paid now
right I mean it's still like more than
I've ever he nuts
compared to the money we make totally
ego he didn't return for it but he got
but Robert Downey got pay like 10
million dollars for Iron Man 2 which is
like what we make on the weekend so good
for
so I imagine all that extra money for
Terrence Howard went over to Robert
Downey for that one damn damn
it must be so tough working on set with
somebody and you have to be like you
have to pretend to be friends and
everything oh my god just watch that
video but like was it sexy or something
really in control and she was saying oh
Jessica Parker no that but it has yeah
did they yeah what control refuses to do
a Sex in the City movie number three it
would be at this point yeah number three
yeah
thankfully probably because that's let's
keep it beautiful yeah interesting
what's funny about the Jim Carrey and
Tommy Lee Jones one that I've heard
about before you guys have all seen
Batman Forever right oh yeah
so hey no I'm kind of surprised by this
one when Tommy Lee Jones is talking
about Jim Carrey's buffoonery right
because Tommy Lee Jones seems like he's
trying to give a Jim Carrey performance
in that movie you like ice cream he's so
over the top yeah and he seems like he's
trying to match the level of Jim Carrey
that's like why would you clown on this
guy if you're gonna try to do something
along the lines of what he's doing you
could just work with him and get you
know maybe some advice on how to do this
and then by the end of this all like I'm
not a big fan of that I don't really
like that movie
[Music]
but a lot of people thought Jim Carrey
was really fun in the movie stupid and
fun it's entertaining bad it's a little
bit of Barry Morris so it's just so
funny yeah it's fun over-the-top I get a
headache when I watch it there oh I love
it something I do I get too excited yeah
I just love it that much I think that's
so incredibly disrespectful and I'm
actually joel schumacher's a director
who doesn't really have the most respect
for some reason because he doesn't come
he's not good at constantly dishing out
good films that's really cool to hear
that he stood up for Jim Carrey of that
matter and did not go out of his way to
like defend Tommy Lee Jones at all
because I feel like a lot of directors
don't really do that anymore
yeah and I'm happy that I took that
approach don't be a dick like doesn't
matter where you are and when you're on
set it's a pressure cooker so you have
to actually be nicer and more flexible
yeah yeah available and help each other
out I'm surprised they didn't put on
here Ryan Gosling and Rachel McAdams I
was just gonna I was thinking about that
too right yeah because that's the most
famous one like it I think people
discuss all the time cuz they fell in
love like way after making that movie
yeah don't worry they eventually had a
really good romance girl making a joke
are you serious yeah it was really it
was really sad because they actually had
to there's no but I think Anna Claus
yeah why does that upset you I just feel
so bad you sold I just you've been
bamboozled but they do such an amazing
job can you hate someone and then love
so I don't get that yeah well I religion
it makes the exactly because it makes me
go maybe that's why their chemistry was
so good because there was really a lot
of it was repressed attraction for one
another
it's just passion and that's why when
they had those scenes notebook it was
like beautiful and romantic
compassionate maybe nine and a half
weeks what's that that make your work I
think your man half weeks where they
feed each other by the refrigerator
almost famous like romantic movie of all
time
and they didn't get along they hated
each other but they had to play like
passion but I think that helped them
actually because they had to be
passionate there might be a line there
then it's like if you don't if you're
doing a romantic film yeah be a dick to
your co-star co-stars that I've had to
kiss and they were like mean to me
before it was hard to do my job you
didn't have a good chemistry with them
though on camera really no well no we
did because I you know I was on this
Lifetime movie and this dude who's like
talking mad crap to me because I I was I
played a nurse and a doctor's office
said in this Lifetime movie and he was I
walked out at the trailer and he looked
at me and he goes oh this is what I have
to work with today
oh I can't see every month and I had no
makeup on I look like a little girl it
was like when I first started acting I
was so that is so offensive what I did I
was like I'm gonna rock that dude's
world and when we did the scene I rocked
his world he asked me out and I said no
wow that is good is so nice jerky I've
done that to so many women to just like
ya mean to them in your position oh yeah
yes it's crazy but it's so mean isn't
that mean that's me you should be on
this was just I know
automatically say something back and it
would not end well alright when I would
not be able to hold it back I think I've
known you for an hour and I would never
be mean to you know seem like a tough
cookie she's tough don't let that
reaction fool you but like so kind to
and Sir John I try we're saying that
because we don't want to get hit later
Russian woman don't
no trick you it's not I'm very cute and
I am nice you get it you good trust the
one who self proclaims themselves to be
cute it's a tough life in Russia you
can't smile for no reason you never know
what people can do smile in Russia if
you're a woman serious like I had to
learn that here we talked about this
like smiling all the time because it's
something that you don't do in Russia
otherwise you're in trouble it's damn
take advantage of your kindness we can
do a whole video about your upbringing
and Russia it's very intense
it's tough if you talk nicely and you
smell nobody's gonna notice you you got
a commune be like hey give me my [ __ ] or
you don't get it well if you think
that's rough Terrence Howard on the gun
offered a million dollars to do the next
Iron Man you cannot compete with your
stories whatever but that that's rough
the Val Kilmer Tom Sizemore one that
one's a funny one to me that's hilarious
why is Val Kilmer upset that he had his
account equipment you son of a [ __ ] how
dare you I think your treadmill over
here just like I think he's a diva like
Tom's eye tomorrow it's being a diva
I think Val Kilmer is also known to be a
bit of a diva yeah
murdock concerns of both of all top
summers been in jail for some pretty
horrendous things but Val Kilmer yeah
I've heard about comer it can be a
pretty big diva - but he's Batman and
Jesus and the Technicolor jury
[Laughter]
Tom sizer didn't say I'm not gonna work
with you on another movie set he said
I'm never going to another planet my
dumbbells
I love it
I wish we were around during the night
it's like I feel like got the glory of
the blockbuster yes yeah could be such a
diva get away with it like those days
are awful you can bake I think it's
really it's liberating nice don't like I
think to keep this light they kept you
notice it was all like men who they were
talking about yeah because they didn't
notice that's a good point I was gonna
say the ones a men and women can be like
[ __ ] horror stories are like yeah
who's like fun like dudes where he goes
down for a second you know well it
sparked a fun discussion yeah co-stars
that he names about yeah like this girl
right there now I adore this girl yeah
I'm happy to be right here in the center
if you want to check out these two crazy
people on the Internet
you can check out their instagrams link
in the description box do you tweet I do
not tweet I have to say I am glad you
are honest I could never get a hang of
it do I have to be witty all the time
and I can't I just use it to vent about
YouTube problems and Kelly is a person
on social media I don't tweet either
because I don't link the pressure of you
know I just don't like the pressure
being funny and yeah the same thing
follow them on Twitter as soon as you
can
subscribe to the rejects that there are
things I should cover with you two
before we know Instagram or grams
Lincoln's great for it you can tweet and
post photos where they cosplay as demons
and just click that notification about
and check us on patreon